radiowissen die ganze Welt des Wissens
ein Podcast von Bayern 2
Radio wissen heute geht es um Neid für
Christen ist er eine der sieben
Todsünden für Buddhisten ein Leid
bringender Geisteszustand im Islam eine
schlechte Eigenschaft und die moderne
Psychologie sagt hör auf dich zu
vergleichen aber kann Neid nicht auch
Ansporn sein für mehr Leistung und eine
gerechtere Gesellschaft
[Musik]
ich mache eine Sendung über den Neid
waren sie schon mal neidisch nein warum
sollte ich das sagen ich könnte jedem
das was er sich erschafft bestimmt
früher mal in der Kindheit oder in der
Jugend das war neidisch auch andere
waren weil die ein Spielzeug hatten was
ich nicht haben durfte vielleicht auf
materielle Produkte war ich glaube ich
neidisch das habe ich mir dann aber
Erwachsenenalter abgewöhnt die deutschen
gelten ja allgemein als unzufrieden und
als äh na ich bin also immer
zurückgesetzt oder so und die anderen
haben mehr wenn einer gierig ist was die
Natur des Menschen normalerweise ist
wenn ich gierig bin dann bin ich auch
weil er hätte vielleicht ein Euro mehr
als ich warum hat er es
und warum habe ich mich
[Musik]
warum bin ich hier und ich anderswo da
wo alle sind
daran auch Neid kann man zunächst mal
beschreiben man ist auf jemanden
neidisch wegen etwas das heißt man
leidet dem anderen ein gut oder eine
Eigenschaft und möchte die selbst haben
sagt Hilde Landwehr Philosophie
Professorin an der Freien Universität
Berlin also man kann natürlich bei
vielen Menschen sagen das Geld was die
haben natürlich auch gerne aber das ist
noch kein echtes Neidgefühl das hat
Gefühl es ist dann wenn sich dieses
bohrende Gefühl damit verbindet ich will
das unbedingt auch haben und es macht
mir was aus dass ich das nicht besitze
oder diese Eigenschaft nicht habe dann
handelt es sich um Neid und ich denke
das jeder hat Gefühle kennt und wer das
leugnet hat ein schlechtes Verhältnis zu
sich selbst
Neid ist die höchste Form der
Bewunderung heißt es aber auch wenn wohl
jeder dieses unangenehmen nagende Gefühl
schon einmal erlebt hat gibt niemand
gerne zu dass er neidisch ist denn Neid
hat keinen guten Ruf in einer Liste von
100 wünschenswerten
Charaktereigenschaften landete neidisch
auf Platz 97
dahinter kamen nur noch engstirnig
falsch und grausam
für Buddhisten ist Neid ein Leid
bringender Geisteszustand im Islam eine
schlechte Eigenschaft die zu Unheil
führen kann und in der Bibel eine der
sieben Todsünden du sollst nicht
begehren deines Nächsten Hab und Gut
meint das zehnte Gebot
[Musik]
also ich bin ja gar nicht neidisch ich
gönne den Leuten in den Auto schöne
Kleider ich sag zwar schon mal ach ich
hätte auch gern schönere Beine gehabt
oder irgendwie aber dass ich den
neidisch bin nee also nee wer war das
nicht schon mal im Leben man will das
irgendwie nicht zugeben das ist
urmenschlich finde ich aber ich doch
nicht das Wort Neid ist einfach
unheimlich negativ geprägt man kann es
natürlich auch positiv sehen sondern als
Blick darauf was anders ist und was ich
persönlich vielleicht noch verändern
verbessern könnte ne wenn ich allein die
Werbung angucke so ja ich habe da ich
habe das und du musst das auch haben und
sowas alles weil er menschgierig ist das
ist der Grund warum der Neid entsteht
sind andere erfolgreich habe ich kein
Problem der Zustand ist wirklich recht
unangenehm ich bin oft sehr neidisch auf
ihr schönes Geld denn Geld wäre auch
gern meine Welt neigt das was jeder ist
keine Ziel doch ich geht es zu er wohnt
doch in mir es hat keinen Zwecke brummt
gib es ruhig zu jeder ist meine genauso
wie Du hier kommt der nice die neidische
Person glaubt in der Regel dass die
Erfolg der anderen Person nicht verdient
sei die neidische Person empfindet Leid
beim Glück eine andere Person sie kann
sich nicht mit der anderen Person freuen
das ist wirklich moralisch problematisch
Jörg Noller vertritt zur Zeit in der
Universität Konstanz den Lehrstuhl für
Praktische Philosophie und beschäftigt
sich schon lange mit Theorien des Bösen
und unmoralischen
den Neid findet er besonders komplex und
spannend der Neid kennt kein Gewinner da
verliert jeder der mai tritt ja auch
nicht wirklich zu Tage direkt wie jetzt
die Wut die Wut entlädt sich nach außen
der Neid der ist nach innen gerichtet
der zerfrisst sich selbst also jemand
der neidisch ist der würde gefragt ob er
neidisch sei immer Antworten ich bin
doch nicht neidisch also wie kommst du
denn darauf für den britischen
Philosophen Francis Bacon ist Neid der
verwerflichste und niedrigste Effekt der
immer einen Grund findet dabei schadet
und quälte in erster Linie den der
neidisch ist seine Seele ist von
Bitterkeit erfüllt und er wird von allen
gehasst denn neidische noch schlimmer
missgünstige Menschen mag man nicht
zu viel negative Energie das bemerkte
Papst Gregor der Große bereits Anfang
des 7 jahrhunderts
des Neid ist das besiegte Herz verdirbt
dann zeigt auch das Äußere an wie schwer
der Wahnsinn den Geist bedrängt die
Farbe wird blass die Augen verschleiert
der Geist entzündet die Glieder kalt das
Denken will die Zähne knirschen
der Neid wurde auch schon bei
Aristoteles definiert als ein
leidenschaftliches Unlustgefühl dass ich
auf das Glück einer anderen Person
bezieht und auch Immanuel Kant spricht
vom Neid als einem Hang das Wohl anderer
mit Schmerz wahrzunehmen obwohl dem
seinen dadurch kein Abbruch geschieht
also der Neid der kann auch so ein
Strudel entwickeln dass man sich etwas
hineinsteigert also Neid und Fanatismus
es stehen sich auch gar nicht so fern
wenn ich das Gefühl habe ich bin
insgesamt zu kurz gekommen ja dann kann
sich seine allgemeine neidhaltung
entwickeln die sich auf alles überträgt
das nennt man dann noch besser und das
ist eine Art heimlicher Groll eine Art
Sucht dafür dass man sich
unverdientermaßen in einer schlechten
Situation sieht der Philosoph Arthur
schuppenhauer verglich den Neid mit
einer giftigen Kröte
Shakespeare nannte ihn ein grünäugiges
Monster das macht mich blind
lass mich
se sagt mich meiner Meinung
bis sie zusammenfällt und mich nicht
ja der Neid ist nicht nur hässlich er
macht auch hässlich
[Musik]
spieglein Spieglein an der Wand wer ist
die schönste im ganzen Land fragt die
Königin in Grimms Märchen den
Zauberspiegel und bekommt zu hören dass
ihre Stieftochter tausendmal schöner ist
als sie
da erschrak die Königin und ward gelb
und grün von Neid von Stund an wenn sie
Schneewittchen erblickte kehrte sich ihr
das Herz im Leibe herum so hasste sie
das Mädchen und der Neid und Hochmut
wuchsen wie ein Unkraut in ihrem Herzen
immer höher dass sie Tag und Nacht keine
Ruhe mehr hatte
also ich denke gerade Neid auf die
Schönheit von anderen ist was ganz
typisches man findet das in der
Literatur ja andauernd die Frage ist
immer in welchem Maße geht es mir darum
dass der andere dieses Gut oder diese
Eigenschaft nicht haben soll oder geht
es mir einfach nur darum dass ich die
auch haben möchte und sehe ich
Möglichkeiten dieses gute diese
Eigenschaft zu erreichen genauso wie bei
der bösen Stiefmutter im Märchen
funktioniert der Neid auch im wahren
Leben jemand vergleicht sich mit einer
anderen Person
fällt dieser Vergleich unvorteilhaft aus
wird das Selbstwertgefühl angekratzt je
geringer die Aussicht ist die eigene
Unterlegenheit zu überwinden desto
feindseliger werden die Gedanken weil
das so ist ist es eben auch nicht schön
beneidet zu werden weil man genau das
wahrnimmt das andere einen in einem
negativen Licht sehen nämlich weil sie
auch die Dinge haben möchten die man
selbst hat
die us-szene des Neides stammt aus der
Bibel da er schlägt kein seinen Bruder
Abel weil Gott seine Opfergabe weniger
schätzt
ein klarer Fall von geschwisterneid
ja entsteht halt viel Hass warum hat er
warum ich nicht und so fängt dann die
letzte Reise wo früher an Neid führt
auch zu vielen
bösartigen singen ich bin neidisch dass
er was hast dann nehme ich ihm das weg
es geht es damit schon
im Sandy sind doch viel schöner und
besser als die eigenen Sachen und wehe
die große Schwester bekommt ein größeres
Eis darf länger am Computer spielen oder
im Auto vorne sitzen voll ungerecht
laut Philosophin hilgelernt wäre kann
man aber längst nicht auf jeden neidisch
sein das Gefühl entsteht wenn man sich
vergleicht und man vergleicht sich
eigentlich nur mit Menschen die einem in
gewissen Hinsichten ähnlich sind also
oft demselben sozialen Milieu angehören
oder nur minimal drüber sind und nur
dann entstehen halt man beneidet
eigentlich nicht jemanden der für einen
selbst unerreichbar ist sondern nur wenn
es eine ganz bestimmte Ähnlichkeit gibt
zwischen dieser Person und mir kann ich
sie beneiden alles tot ist spricht davon
dass man eigentlich nur auf jemanden
neidisch sein kann ich zitiere mal der
nach Berechtigung Stellung im Leben
unseresgleichen ist ein armer Arbeiter
wird also nicht den Reichen
Fabrikbesitzer beneiden sondern den
Nachbarn der etwas mehr verdient als er
Neid verrät aber auch etwas darüber was
den Menschen wichtig ist und was er
gerne hätte
die Beförderung des Kollegen ein Haus
mit Garten wie die beste Freundin ein
Abenteuer Urlaub am anderen Ende der
Welt neidisch sein kann man auf alles
und jeden doch am stärksten ausgeprägt
ist der Neid unter Freunden Bekannten
und Kollegen
aber handelt es sich bei dem Wunsch auch
das haben zu wollen was andere haben
tatsächlich immer um Neid
Jörg Noller bezweifelt das man sagt
häufig im Alltag ich beneide dich das
kennt jeder damit ist dann eigentlich
nur eine Form von Bewunderung gemeint
jeder der sagt ich beneide dich der
gönnt einem gerade den schönen Urlaub
oder den Erfolg oder was auch immer aber
wenn der Wunsch von diesem leiblichen
spüren begleitet ist dass man so ein
bohrendes nagendes Gefühl hat dass der
andere so einen tollen Urlaub gemacht
hat während man selbst nicht wegfahren
konnte oder nicht das Geld hat dann ist
das natürlich ein Gefühl und das Gefühl
ist der neidisch
[Musik]
zu verstehen er wird es besser geht wer
neidisch ist zieht nur den Mangel und
findet immer wieder ein neues Objekt der
Begierde wir können dem Neid nicht
entgehen weil wir Vergleiche ziehen und
der Maßstab dafür ist immer der oder die
anderen
alle modernen westlichen Gesellschaften
werden beherrscht von Wettbewerbs und
Konkurrenzdenken wir wetteifern um die
paul-position und das Messen von
Leistungen Kenntnissen Fertigkeiten und
Kompetenzen ist an der Tagesordnung
schon die Kleinstkinder werden
regelmäßig untersucht und müssen
bestimmte Standards erfüllen sie müssen
mit sechs Monaten das und das Können und
mit 18 Monaten dann was anderes und so
weiter und das setzt sich dann in der
Schule und womöglich in der Ausbildung
oder an der Universität fortan das
Wohnsystem ist natürlich dieses pseudo
objektivierte
leistungsmessungsinstrument was dazu
führt dass natürlich auch Neid befördert
wird in der modernen
Leistungsgesellschaft vergleichen wir
uns mit anderen neuerdings auch über
soziale Medien im Internet permanent wir
vergleichen uns mit Blick auf Geld
Erfolg Schönheit wir zeigen auch Symbole
des Wohlstands Autos Uhren und so weiter
also sie werden permanent konfrontiert
mit Erfolgen mit Werten und das wird
natürlich auch zu Entstehung von
neidgefühlen
aber was haben wir eigentlich davon dass
wir neidisch sind
warum wollen wir so unbedingt genau das
haben was andere besitzen
der schottische Moralphilosoph Adam
Smith sagt wir sind neidisch weil wir
glauben wenn wir das alles auch hätten
dass wir dann zufrieden und glücklich
werden die permanente Jagd nach mehr
Geld mehr Prestige mehr Klamotten ein
größeres Auto ein eigenes Haus ist die
Triebfeder unserer Konsumgesellschaft
befeuert wird sie von der Werbung und
den sozialen Medien aber auch wenn Neid
nicht zu den bevorzugten Eigenschaften
zählt hat er doch eine gewisse
Ambivalenz laut Aristoteles kann er
berechtigt sein wenn es eine ungerechte
Verteilung gibt
[Musik]
im Naht geht es ja erstmal darum dass
jemand anderes was hat was ich auch
haben möchte und das kann eben auch die
nerance haben dass ich meine darauf
Anspruch zu haben und das ist der
Übergang zu einem Gerechtigkeitsgefühl
wenn ich meine auf etwas Anspruch zu
haben was andere bekommen dann kann sich
ein ganz anderes Gefühl entwickeln als
Neid nämlich Zorn oder Empörung der
englische Philosoph Francis Bacon
spricht von öffentlichen Neid wenn das
Volk dagegen protestiert dass die da
oben sich die Taschen voll machen aber
wer über das Unfassbare Vermögen von
multimilliardären wie Chef bases und
Elon Musk meckert wer die Millionen
schweren Boni von Bankern und
konzernmanagern missbilligt oder die
horrenten Ablösesummen von Fußballstars
lautstark kritisiert wird nicht wirklich
vom Neid getrieben sagt Jörg Noller und
erklärt den Unterschied ich glaube nicht
dass es im String Sinne im moralischer
Neid ist dafür gibt es zu wenig
Vergleichspunkte das ist ein
ungerechtigkeitsgefühl was aber ganz
bewusst artikuliert wird in solchen
Fällen protestieren die Menschen
durchaus auch zurecht die gehen auf die
Straße artikulieren ihre Empörung im
night hingegen wird die Empörung
gewissermaßen runtergeschluckt und
findet fast gar kein Ventil weswegen ihm
derjenige der neidisch ist häufig sich
selbst zermürbt sich zurückzieht grübelt
und eine finstere Mine zieht vielleicht
sogar auch gar nicht sich den Neid
ansehen lässt während die Menschen die
gegen Ungerechtigkeit protestieren eben
alles nach außen entladen ihre Meinung
kundtun und auch dazu stehen dass das
ungerecht ist laut Francis Bacon richtet
sich der öffentliche Neid gegen die
herrschenden um sie in die Schranken zu
weisen und dient dem Wohl der
Allgemeinheit auch der Politiker Walter
Rathenau war überzeugt
Gerechtigkeit entspringt dem Neider
denn ihr oberster Satz ist allen das
gleiche
wer die Kritik an unverhältnismäßigen
Besitzverhältnissen als neid-kampagne
abtut versucht damit die berechtigte
Empörung über ungerechte Zustände zu
verunglimpfen auch der berühmte Penis
Neid also Sigmund Freuds these das
Frauen Männer um ihr Geschlechtsteil
beneiden ist ein beliebter Vorwurf um
die Forderung nach mehr Frauen in
Führungspositionen lächerlich zu machen
denn wer neidisch ist der hat kein Recht
auf mehr ja sicherlich wird Neid der
Begriff des Nades politisch
funktionalisiert also klassisch im
Begriff des sozialnals also das denke
ich schon dass man manche Empörung als
Neid diskreditieren kann weil Neid eben
ein Gefühl ist was niemand haben möchte
und was negativ bewertet wird und wenn
jemand neidisch ist dann ist das auf
alle Fälle schlecht werden wenn jemand
empört ist dann könnte ja was dran sein
an der Empörung
[Musik]
nicht immer hat das gelbe Monster Böses
im Sinn
wer begehrt was andere haben ohne sich
zu wünschen sie hätten es nicht für den
kann Neid auch motivierend sein während
der missgünstige das Glück oder Talent
der anderen die erfolgreiche sind
schlecht macht und am liebsten zerstören
will versucht der gutartige Neider mit
Ausdauer Energie und Fleiß mit dem
anderen gleich zu ziehen ich war
eigentlich immer eine gute Schülerin
aber es gab dann immer noch so eine die
war immer noch ein bisschen besser und
dann habe ich mich angestrengt und dann
war ich plötzlich auch so gut Neid kann
auch Leistung hervorrufen Ansporn kann
sein wenn ich sehe was manche leisten
können dass ich dann in
Anführungszeichen neidisch bin aber das
vielleicht dann mehr als Antrieb sehe
selbst zu gucken was kann ich noch tun
um meine persönlichen Ziel Ideale zu
verwirklichen
der Philosoph Martin Seel unterscheidet
in seinem Buch 111 Tugenden 111 Laster
den generösen vom aggressiven Neid
Menschen die auf großzügige Art neidisch
sind können Unterschiede akzeptieren und
für das eigene Leben wertvoll machen
auch wenn sie sich ständig mit anderen
vergleichen nutzen Sie das Gefühl des
Neides um sich weiterzuentwickeln leider
als Antrieb Neid als Startpunkt Neid als
Vergleichsmöglichkeit
Neid als Orientierung wo steht man
eigentlich wo stehe ich wo sind die
anderen Neid als Erkenntnismethode Neid
auch als Mittel herauszufinden was will
ich eigentlich wo sind meine Präferenzen
das spürt man im Neid auch sehr deutlich
also ihm nein erkennen wir uns
eigentlich selbst und so sollte man den
Neid verstehen Neid als Selbsterkenntnis
und Kraft weiterzukommen
[Musik]
für Jörg Noller ist eine Welt ohne Neid
undenkbar da Menschen sich ständig mit
anderen vergleichen und noch höheren
Streben ist niemand vor dem nagenden
gefühlt das sahen die griechischen
Philosophen der Antike ganz anders für
Platon ist der vollkommene Mensch frei
von Neid und Missgunst besonnen und
Weise
das moralische ideal ist ein Zustand der
Seelenruhe und Ausgeglichenheit doch wie
lässt sich die giftige Kröte Neid zähmen
Hilge Landwehr ich glaube nicht dass es
ein Patentrezept der neidvermeidung gibt
sondern man kann nur bewusst mit seinen
Gefühlen umgehen und sehen dass man sich
darüber klar wird was man wirklich will
und alle Kraft dafür einzusetzen dass
auch zu erreichen und
insofern glaube ich nicht dass dieses
Gefühl ganz und gar vermieden werden
kann ich denke aber dass man damit in
sehr unterschiedlicherweise umgehen kann
wenn schon einen Grund haben entweder
ich muss was dafür tun dass ich ihm
gleichgestellt bin oder ich muss einfach
damit leben wenn du nichts tust kriegst
auch nichts ganz einfach zu denken was
habe ich denn alles schönes und dann
legt sich das ganz schnell man sollte
zufrieden sein mit dem was man hat ne
also ich glaube Glück definiert sich
nicht darüber was man an materiellen
Wert hat sondern das Leben an sich wie
man selber gestaltet ne
abgesehen davon dass Neider und
beneidete sich gleichermaßen schlecht
fühlen hat Neid keinerlei Effekt
der römische Philosoph senekar schlägt
darum vor auf den Vergleich mit anderen
am besten komplett zu verzichten denn
wie kann man glücklich sein wenn man
sich darüber ärgert dass ein anderer
glücklicher ist
das Fazit lautet je zufriedener ich
damit bin wie ich bin und was ich habe
desto weniger nagt der Neid
bereits im fünften Jahrhundert vor
Christus empfiehlt der griechische
Philosoph demokret nicht nach dem
unerreichbaren zu schielen sondern sich
darauf zu besinnen was man hat und sich
mit denen zu vergleichen denen es
schlechter geht
und auch Kinder wissen intuitiv wie sich
Neid vermeiden lässt die große Luise
wollte mal einen Ratschlag machen aber
aber sie hat nur sie Beine so krumm
geschafft dann habe ich ihr geholfen
der Neid das gelbe Gift dass wir wohl
alle kennen eine Podcast Folge von
Claudia heißenberg vielleicht
interessiert Sie auch ein Radio Wissen
über Egoismus als neue Lebensform oder
das Gefühl der Zerrissenheit alle Folgen
überall wo es Podcasts gibt